coach of the year very well could be
john harbaugh for the second straight
year if he keeps making decisions like
he did yesterday
and remember and you know i we hear this
from time to time like when there's a
team on the road and there's a close
controversial call the home team doesn't
play it
on the jumbotron or whatever hell they
call those things now
uh and yesterday there was a play that
nobody thought
would potentially be overturned marcus
peters has the ball
uh and then he doesn't it looks like an
incomplete pass harbaugh told me after
the game i thought it was incomplete but
then he looked up
and he saw the big board and he saw it
replayed
and he saw marcus peters get two hands
on the ball
he saw three feet hit the ground he
remembered that the rule now
when they finally tried to come up with
an objective standard that meets the
subjective gut level feeling that we
know it when we see it
they have the rule that says if you have
the ball and you get three feet down
it's a catch so he threw the red
challenge flag concluding it was a catch
and now riveron agreed and shireen
this was one where i wanted to pounce
i wanted to say this is another example
of how river on just reading off of a
card all the words he has to say
even if the words don't match the video
i had that story ready to go
and i watched the video one more time
and i watched it again
i watched it again and i watched the
feet while i watched
you know with peripheral vision the the
hands
on the ball then i watched the hands on
the ball while i watched the feet with
peripheral vision
and you know what peter's had both hands
on the ball and he got three feet down
and it doesn't have to trigger that
inner
hey that's a catch if you have the ball
in your hands and you get three feet
down
it's a catch harbaugh was right and
river one
was right even though when you watch it
it feels like it was wrong
somebody in indy was fired today
probably mike for sure
or if they want if they weren't they
definitely were reprimanded for sure but
i i was opposite i i didn't think he had
control of the ball and
you know reich said that he that third
foot really made the big difference he
thought although he still disagreed that
that it was a catch
but i went back today and watched the
play because i'm like okay
well if it was a catch then it was a
fumble so i first looked on the
play-by-play sure enough they ruled a
fumble
and then i watched to see if there was a
clear recovery
who recovered the ball and sure enough
the ravens picked up the ball
smartly so if if the colts had picked up
the ball there they would
have they would have had the ball and
you know maybe they would have
challenged
they would have had to challenge it
because obviously the ravens wouldn't at
that point
because it was a fumble so that was an
interesting point part of the play too
that no one's really talking about and i
think it it
defensive coordinators today offensive
coordinators both should be telling
their guys
go pick up the ball just to be sure hand
it to an official
because it could be ruled a fumble
remember that screwy outcome
from the bears eagles playoff game 2018
where there was
something like this where the ball just
laid there
and the end result was even though it
was
a catch and a fumble the end result was
it was incomplete because there was
nothing that could ultimately be
overturned because nobody ultimately
secured possession
of the loose ball that was that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports